wearing the same things as last week
guys we haven't changed for a whole week
I have engaged in a whole week just
kidding it is the same night weird we're
stocking up on podcasts tonight going
off Straley out for YouTube fans so we
won't be in town when this podcast is up
that's why we're doing it ahead of time
so when you're not filthy we're not
wearing the same clothes all week no
need for those comments but we just had
a great podcast and now we're you
another awesome one yeah this podcast is
brought to you by me undies may I need
some of the most comfortable underwear
in the entire world at me and ease calm
go check them out twice the softest
cotton guys that's a pretty sweet claim
me and ease calm slash Jenna Julian gets
you 20% off her first pair and they only
they have been a great supporter of our
podcast awesome support you me undies
and I love when you guys tweet us that
you got some me unease because I
supports us supports us it helps out the
podcast and yeah ah Thank You muties
thank you so I'm ready for this I'm so
ready for this
yes we usually do this the other way
around yeah I'll be like Julie not
really really want to talk about
something right now and you know you can
you can have like your thoughts and
maybe plays devil's advocate if you want
to but like I'll just think of something
that I really want to talk about Julian
right now has come to me and was like I
have something I want to talk about yep
I wanted to talk about Miley Cyrus
alright I'm ready to poke holes and or
agree with you and or disagree with you
all of them I'm very frustrated with
Miley Cyrus lately all right well where
do you want to start let's see well
really fair the the VMAs were last night
I'm just gonna say we're a day removed
weird a move right now from the VMAs but
when you see this podcast it'll be it'll
be a week I am I've been fed up with her
for a little while this was just kind of
the straw that made me want to make a
podcast about it question off the top
yeah how do you feel about Billy Ray's
performance at the VMAs he killed it as
always
daddy did I'm dying laughing when I saw
him in those sunglasses and oh my god I
was living this living okay um
I am fed up with Miley Cyrus okay I'm
fed up with her stick and I wrote
something out called the subsections of
Miley's failing shtick sounds harsh
which are a bunch of reasons why I think
what she's doing is completely the
opposite of what she thinks she's doing
I'm done so I guess I'll start it off
with she thinks that she's so in touch
with everyone in pop culture that she
makes herself further out of touch than
she even was to begin with
and this applies to any entity to which
she attaches herself with so what this
means is when she is in the public eye
and says something say hosting the VMAs
I'm gonna use that example a lot when
she says something that she thinks is
clever and funny and in reality it's not
it's not clever nor funny nor relevant
and she in her own mind a hundred
percent thinks that she's doing a good
job she's being a pop culture star she's
pleasing the crowd and she's she's being
smart and quippy when in reality it's so
not funny and it's so not relevant and
not with the times that it's like wow
that was a great example of how
completely wrong and out of it you are
in your brain so the example I have for
that when she makes a comment like hey
Justin call me when you're legal like
she did last night at the VMAs or we
could go for you guys it shows how both
she thought that clip was clever or
funny while also somehow properly times
which was the second part of why I hated
that
in my opinion right now Justin Bieber is
the most appealing to me he's ever been
he seems to be pretty apparently moving
past his teenage shenanigans and more
importantly he seems to be really taking
his music seriously and his craft
seriously and I can respect that and to
be honest with you I've been enjoying
everything he's put out in the last
around year I think a lot of people are
starting to have him grow on them I
can't help respect what he's doing he
made a pretty awesome return to the VMA
stage he hadn't been there in a bunch of
years he came back and killed it in my
opinion he did an awesome job singing
and even more importantly a [ __ ] dope
ass job dancing which we all know he was
not that great of a dancer at one point
so he's clearly been working on and
after he finished the song he broke down
and he started to cry because it was
such an emotional moment for him he
realized like he kept it together he did
a great job and he returned to the stage
and in his mind and it was a was an
awesome experience and it was so
visceral that he broke down crying and
not even like a 30 milliseconds later
Miley comes on with that joke like call
me when you're legal first of all how
old is Justin Bieber he's like 22 right
now I don't know I'll look it up look at
all of you hello um the joke is outdated
it's been made thousands of times before
when he was young and people would talk
to him like under 8 he's not under 18
not even close under 18 that's not a
funny joke it's not even an accurate
joke and it's not a joke that's never
been made it's been made a hundred times
way before that instead she felt like it
was a necessary moment to interrupt
someone like she did throughout the show
and make it another cringe moment he's
21 he's 21
four years ago maybe that joke would
have been relevant not even not even
though cuz everyone had already said it
a million times
hey jazz uncommon illegal so that kind
of joke where she thinks she's being
clever like she's clearly so I'm not
going to say she's high cuz I'm not she
was high but she she's clearly so like
alter all the time that she's so out of
touch to the point where she's going to
say something like that not not only
just in general but at a moment where it
was so not welcomed that is number one
okay should I give you a response if you
want if you wanted okay combat
everything I have and I love for the
sake of fun I'll give you a respond no I
mean I understand where you're coming
from and I understand you're saying I do
think that some of her jokes weren't
really jokes they were kind of cringe II
um to her own credit I think that she's
young and she's a musician she doesn't
do hosting gigs and I think a lot of the
content that they were making like the
pre-recorded segments we're all sort of
playing off of the same joke which is
that Miley likes to do a lot of drugs
and then there's point um I think that
she did an incredible job given the fact
that she's a young girl herself with a
lot of pressure on her shoulders to host
an entire award show when there hasn't
been a host in a couple of years and
that she hasn't done it anything like
that before
you think she did an incredible job
hosting I didn't say incredible I think
she did incredible given the
circumstances of who she is and yeah I
mean it wasn't work the worst it wasn't
not entertaining I was entertained and I
for one just in general I think I know
where you're going with most of your
argument I think that she is not trying
to be relevant in okay
what no I just like you're you're caught
you're hitting on a bunch of points that
I'm going to say oh maybe I should just
read all my points and then have you a
bomb is that fair
sure okay I'll really down okay alright
so number two she's okay so advocating
for weed is one thing
being a living breathing billboard of
Wyatt can be stupid is a completely
different thing and I thought she's not
only like last night was a great example
because every every [ __ ] joke made
that she made on the stage in the skit
in the sketches everything was weed and
I was like so fed up I was like this is
not funny it wasn't funny the first joke
because you know weed jokes can be funny
but they weren't they weren't funny
they were overplayed they were overdone
overused and like everyone is expecting
you to be like everyone is expecting you
to make a weed joke why do you have to
do it over and over like be something
that you are not going to become a
character of like in two seconds because
right now you're a living like I said a
living breathing example of why weed has
a bad name next to it okay not saying I
don't like weed or I mean I don't smoke
me but not saying I don't like I don't
advocate for weed or being legal I'm not
putting a stance on that all I'm saying
is she is not giving it a good look
she's not being a great ambassador for
the plant if you will okay
point number three her staying relevant
any way possible is only made possible
by feeding the freak show ie MTV asking
her to host I'm sorry but there were so
many other people that could have hosted
the VMAs and not made a mockery of
themselves not made a mockery of their
generation of a drug of so many things I
was just so like over it and I was like
you know I'll give her a chance I'll see
what she does maybe she hosts well maybe
she wins me back or makes me feel like
you know she's least a little in touch
nope
she completely confirmed every belief I
didn't want to have that Miley is just
so far gone down the rabbit hole of
being drugged out or being just kind of
insane a little bit and uh MTV allowed
that to happen I asked her to host so
she's only going to be as relevant as
people let her if he gets
gigs because people want to be like hey
we have this crazy polarizing like Miley
who's like clearly lost her mind a
little bit she's gonna host our ward
show isn't that great yeah people are
gonna watch but you're it's like it's
it's kind of a circus it's not like a
real host it's not quality television
it's not something that you're watching
while not cringing it you're cringing
the whole time okay so a little a little
the blame is on people like MTV who-who
feed it and before she makes a mockery
of actual provocative and talented
figures such as Lady gaga
I think Lady Gaga is very talented she's
kind of a pioneer she's nothing like
anyone has ever been in my opinion and
both with her music with her presence
with her outfits with all of her
performances she is something that's
very very different and you look at
something like Lady Gaga and if you're
an artist you could be inspired by it
and you could say wow that is very cool
whatever she's doing I don't know how to
put a word on it I don't know how to put
it in a box because you can't but
whatever it is I like it I'm inspired by
it that's one thing another thing is to
make a mockery of it which is what I
think Miley is doing with all of our
outfits last night those those just
screamed to me put me in the same
category as Lady Gaga look at me like
you look at her when she comes out in an
outrageous outfit like I want to be Lady
Gaga so bad except you're not going to
walk the walk you're not going to put on
an album all year you're not going to
get any respect from anyone even if Lady
Gaga pisses people off she's [ __ ]
talented period our food just got here
so I think they're barking at that and I
feel like it's frustrating for me
because I see I see
right through it and I think a lot of
people can see right through it so we go
out there for a sec yeah yeah yeah okay
I'll be right back we'll take a quick
break
all right sorry we are we're back I'm
gonna I'm just starting now I guess to
write down some box okay so I just
finished
I think the Lady Gaga portion I think it
really just comes down to everything
about those outfit changes and the fact
that I mean I'm not going to get to the
nip slip yet that will come later
everything about her outfits and just it
just really felt like she wanted like
there's so many things that lady I'm
like really free like frustrated because
she really like made me upset last night
there are so many things that Lady Gaga
did to get to where she is now she made
music real music incredible music not
saying Mama's not capable of that she
made a lot of really crazy music crazy
music videos she's literally showed up
at award shows at performances looking
like an insane person with what she was
dressed as she's in every sense of the
word wore her brand on her sleeve as
much as she could and I felt like Miley
just skipped all that and just dressed
crazy and was like look at me like you
look into Lady Gaga that's how it felt
she didn't say that that's how I thought
next point
her attempts at making news / getting
people to talk about her / doing
shocking things are not calculated
they're a byproduct of her constant
last-ditch efforts at staying relevant
ie the nip-slip when people do things
like publicity stunts and weird things
that are going to make people freak out
and talk about them for weeks normally
they're at least a little bit calculated
and by calculated I mean it was thought
through someone's brain at least once
the way that nip-slip went last night
and I don't know for a fact this is just
my opinion is Miley was naked because
she was changing and she was like oh I'm
not ready why don't I just hold the
court curtain up to myself and maybe oh
I'll accidentally you know what I mean
like I feel like she kind of just at
as in his instance last night was like
what if I do this people will [ __ ]
talk about it like it wasn't calculated
it was stupid it wasn't tasteful it was
like watching a middle-aged person who's
started to lose a little bit and is
desperately tried to fit in with a young
generation we all know that person we've
all seen that middle-aged person who's
gone a little bit out of their minds and
tried to just seem cool but then been so
apparently out of touch and like wow
this is just this is bad like stop Miley
feels like that Miley feels like that
person who's kind of lost it and she is
so past not having an idea of where to
be in in pop culture that she's like
actively pushing herself further away
from being taken seriously or respect it
last point it's not really a point it's
just a note she's not polarizing she's
just annoying mm that's I got hmm okay
I'm gonna try my best to unpack most of
your points as much as I can hmm
but I'm missed some of the beginning
ones cuz I wasn't writing them down I
thought I was gonna be maybe easier to
remember everything he's definitely
didn't glue it um first thing I agree
with your Justin Bieber points I you
know there's some speculation as to
whether or not this image clean up that
he's going through is genuine or not or
if he's just trying to clean it up and
reap the benefits of that we there's
speculation that they're not sure that
he's actually changing that he's doing
it because it's not a good look any
totally fair I just I do want to say
that I'm buying into it right and I
agree with that point 100% I think that
he is you know so clearly at least
putting in a lot of work in his career
and doing the best that he can to make
better decisions as an adult
and I think that he's making good music
and you know doing good stuff anyways um
the the point you made about the jokes
the first of all let me just say about
the
jokes again as I was saying earlier I
think that these were things that were
orchestrated for her and they were all
harping on the same point do I think
that Miley just sits around and takes
drugs all day no I think that she likes
to smoke recreational marijuana I like
to think that for someone with a
schedule like she must have you know
obviously she'll have time off and
things like that but it's not like she's
sitting around doing drugs all day it's
just not possible with a schedule like
that to you know just be tripping your
[ __ ] balls off um I like to think
that she plays it up that that is her
image that she's a free spirit and that
she just does drugs and makes [ __ ]
arts and crafts at home I think that
that's a having people believe that
that's what her life entails is only
helping the brand that she's trying to
get across right now do I think that she
actually can know just like I wasn't
buying for one second then Kesha was
really brushing her teeth the Jack
Daniels when you're on Good Morning
America at 5:30 in the [ __ ] morning
it's just not possible you can't be
drunk in doing this yeah yeah yeah or
else you get caught yeah I mean um I do
think however that it was a misstep on
MTV's part to play into the whole drug
thing over and over and over again like
at what point did someone not say hey
guys isn't this joke a little tired
I thought the Instagram bit was funny
Lacey remark I was like cuz it was it
was genuine it was like it was a cool
idea and it was funny because it's like
you look at her Instagram you're like
what the [ __ ] is this so it was a funny
joke that was the only one that I liked
and it was like not even her was them
right um yeah the Snoop Dogg bit was
really awful and some of the other ones
weren't as good but mostly you know from
my opinion because there's plenty of
[ __ ] cheesy award show jokes that get
made every single year at every single
award show I can stomach some bad bits
and some bad jokes you don't have to
really knock it out of the park for me
to be okay with it I think that by the
they made it to the Snoop Dogg bit I'm
like alright guys you know I think that
you're vastly overestimating who your
audience is yeah by thinking that
everyone thinks that we jokes are really
funny yeah but you know as we're we're
agreeing on this point that somebody
should have had a better eye for editing
those jokes down maybe to like one or
two here and there and every time they
did cut to her alive it was very much
like oh no we don't know meeting a
brownie oh oh every joke in the book
every joke in the weed but it was made
uh but I mean that goes that goes back
to what I said it's like you have to put
fault on MTV for feeding into it with
this [ __ ] um yeah I I'm waiting for the
first like disagree to go to that point
I think that oh well let me preface this
okay so I think I've read an article or
at least a quote from Miley Cyrus saying
that when she's doing sort of all these
over-the-top things you know they're
great they're fun or whatever but she
wore like a regular what looks like a
regular outfit to some recent event and
some journalists had slammed her as like
when she's not doing all these crazy
things then Miley is really boring and
but that's well let me finish I'll let
you finish I think that's such a sad
reality that I'm not saying that it's
good or bad I'm saying that this is the
reality that maybe this particular
marketing strategy has created for her
that once you sort of make your living
off of shocking people if you decide
that you want to stop shocking people
you have to do it in a way that people
can make sense of or give them a reason
to pay attention to you otherwise you
don't I mean that's the part where I
fail to find it in me to respect her
because I feel like people are always
going to call you boring if you don't do
what you're known for
so now Miley has become known for being
a shock factor being kind of wild and
different and weird because she's
created that you know that's where she's
taken herself in her image and her brand
so in any situation similar people are
always
to say if you don't do that you're
boring so it's always going to be that
factor compelling that person to
continue that stick what I don't respect
my Lee for is not only like not go not
not you know making whatever I don't
know what I want my Lee to be doing I
just know it's not this and I'm sure she
can make great music still that's not
the kind of music that she's she can
she's down I know she's talented I've
heard some songs of hers everyone has
heard songs of Miley's that were not bad
like party in the USA like yeah it was
it was very top 40 whatever and it was a
while ago but that's not bad music you
made that you are a hundred percent
capable of making lots more hits and
hits not [ __ ] that people are looking at
because it's crazy but just see I
fundamentally disagree with you there
maybe it's someone's goal not just a
pump out poppy hits that's fine I think
that at least what Miley is currently
doing is making music that resonates
with her on a personal level I mean yeah
party snoozer party in the USA is a
great song I mean but I don't really
know a person that's gonna listen to
that and be like yeah dude this [ __ ]
[ __ ] change my life not at all I
don't mean I don't think there's
anything wrong with someone making music
that speaks to their soul and that
reflects what they're really thinking
every day but I just don't think that's
what Smiley's doing I think she's trying
to do you think she's selling shock
value yeah I think she's like look how
crazy I'm being you're gonna
automatically look at this and then say
oh wow she's deep and weird and stay
relevant like that I feel like it's it's
like just not real it's just not real to
me well let me let me paint you a
possible other scenario Miley is a child
star her father was a singer mm-hmm is
it possible that she just was raised in
a household where you're praised for
creativity you're you're praised for
doing whatever you want and she's been a
working individual for many years now
that this really is an expression of
herself
sure that's possible I just think that
she can continue expressing yourself
without so much of the [ __ ] that's
pissed
well okay here's another point that I
think is important that I had read on
Twitter
someone was praising Miley Cyrus for you
know having not very many clothes on
during the VMAs because what it's
actually doing is its desensitizing
people to the female form which i think
is a really cool and important thinking
thought thing good sentence Jenna thank
you like if you think about it in that
way I will disagree with that she is in
theory helping us become desensitized to
the female form and that it's not all
sexual and that if you're wearing
something that's hardly even there hey
guys this is my body it's in your face
and she does that relentlessly through
social media and sure I think some of it
might be shock value and some of it
might be actually her some of it might
be just you want some attention who
knows who cares
I a lot of us have been in our young 20s
and I know what it's like to want some
attention yeah yeah yeah but I think
that she is doing some good okay by
being so shocking whether whether it be
her her work with the homeless LGBTQ
LMNOP youth sorry I just added on a
bunch of letters because I forgot which
order there's a lot of loners no
disrespect I just forgot which letter
they wanted so I just added a bunch
LGBTQ yeah I think LMNOP um homeless
youth and uh just being an advocate for
gay rights and a legalization of
marijuana just oh but let me finish I
think that she's doing a good job at
using her voice for good and using her
body for some good even if it's not her
intention or she's set out to do that
it's always important I think when you
see a woman that is clearly liberated in
a lot of ways that many of us wish that
we were she's helping people to stop
thinking that everything is about sex or
about drugs that its might
be about freedom okay I'm sorry I mean
you came off
um I'm not going to disagree with that I
think you're right that you know the the
her ability to show off parts of her
body that aren't traditionally shown off
in in the context of what she is I I
don't think that's a bad thing
I think it is absolutely contributing to
the dissents it to sensitization of
naked bodies in this country because
that is that is an issue like people are
people freaked out at that [ __ ]
right look like a Victoria's Secret
model we want you to put it away and
like in our last podcast we talked about
Kim Kardashian no she also casually made
it okay to be a fuller figured woman
yeah
no I'm ready to find the norm of
attractive yeah no for sure anything you
know that's a that's all it's important
for if you're a skinny girl like Miley
you're putting that out there too
yeah this is beautiful I'm beautiful my
body is beautiful and I'm not sorry for
you seeing it I think you have a good
point okay I think I think you have a
good point I think we have a lot of
[ __ ] up issues with that kind of stuff
in this country and I think I'm sure
that what Miley is doing is contributing
to desensitizing people for for whatever
reason they're desensitize in a not
sexual way in just a liberty way yeah no
I I can appreciate that I can't honestly
and I don't want this podcast to come
off as me just [ __ ] on Miley I don't
like I know I'm being intense and I
thought this out but I think just I
really got bugged watching her last
night thinking that she was doing stuff
that she wasn't yeah no I understand
that I see your point that in watching
her performance last night watching her
host the show it can absolutely be read
without question that this is all kind
of an act it's all kind of for shock
value it's all like the lowest hanging
fruit of how to get the other pay
attention on you yeah I can understand
that argument wholeheartedly okay thank
you um and you know I don't I don't
think she's incapable of doing shocking
things and being a shocking purse
and successfully and tastefully like I
think she can absolutely do that and I
think she has done certain things that
have been tasteful and and good you know
yeah well you brought Lady gaga and my
two cents on Lady Gaga is that she is
undeniably talented and wonderful
unfortunately I think when she started
this is just an opinion when she started
you can't fit her into a box of a pop
star you know you're not quite beautiful
or sexy enough to be able to sell the
sex that really sells in pop yeah you
know which I think was kind of
intentional on her part but she didn't
dress like well yeah let me just finish
I'm just I'm just adding that in because
you're saying she wasn't as beautiful or
she didn't fit into that beauty standard
I think that was partly intentional on
her part well let me just finish she's
not marketable as the pop star the way
that pop was there was no place for a
person like that you're really really
talented but I imagine how many doors
got slammed in her face no because she's
just a very normal looking girl she's
not like Britney Spears you're not an
all-american we can't sell you to sell
Abercrombie jeans you know what I mean
think of the Jessica Simpson's the
Britney Spears Christina Aguilera all
these people that are selling pop music
because there's mostly selling sex and
beauty and all Americanists and then you
have somebody maybe like pink where her
image is very like [ __ ] all you [ __ ]
and I'm gonna sing pseudo rock songs and
whatever I want that's her image yeah
they couldn't really figure out an image
for Lady Gaga to have so I think it's
interesting that you're pointing out
that you don't like Miley for selling
shock value when in theory all Lady Gaga
sold us with shock value just felt so
much more substantial with Lady gaga
and it has well do you think that maybe
that's possible because because she's
already done it yes but also because
Lady Gaga maybe isn't selling you drugs
and although she
she has as much as Miley has in my
opinion solji drugs and no okay she but
she doesn't put in your face like Miley
does okay okay but that the the
theatrics the costumes all of that is a
vessel for you to listen to her voice
and take her seriously because we need a
reason to see who you are first because
we overlooked you because you looked
like everyone else so I think her
marketing strategy to get her voice out
there was art you know what I mean
making it a visual performance as much
as it is an audio performance okay so I
think that Miley is using the same
strategy that Lady Gaga did but
unfortunately what I think is happening
with Lady Gaga now is because the masses
were consuming her product because they
were like really excited about this
shocking art that was happening like her
BMA performance when there's blood all
over her you know fast forward a few
years later and she's having a throw-up
artist throwing up on her while she's
performing and everyone doesn't care
anymore
because when you start selling shock
value all you can ever do is one up
yourself until you can't one-up yourself
anymore so you know it barely made any
headlines that she's got this puke
performer drinking green liquid and then
throwing it up on Lady gaga while she's
performing and this is art because you
can't shock us anymore
I think what's difficult about Miley
Cyrus is that yes she's selling a shock
but even over the course of two years
now we're kind of a little bit not
shocked anymore yeah you know so that's
the danger in selling shock absolutely I
don't think it's a bad idea I don't see
anything wrong with it and I think that
a lot of people that appreciate Lady
Gaga and appreciate Miley maybe like
it's you're not really paying attention
because of the shock I will listen to
your music and hear you out regardless
yeah
and Lady Gaga's music is wonderful no
matter what you know you have to reel it
in and
and go from there like she did her whole
Tony Bennett album and stuff that's
that's where you go from shock value you
go you go back to square one and say all
right I got people's attention now now
now I want people to listen to my music
and take me seriously so I think
naturally Miley might phase out of
shocking us and back into a place where
hey guys just want you to take my music
seriously thanks
well I'm honestly hoping for that and I
think that right now is just kind of an
odd middle period for her like a weird
transition period can we take a quick
break
and say thanks to me Angie me undies is
sponsoring this podcast guys this is an
underwear company twice as soft as
cotton it's an amazing material we have
a bunch of pairs and I think we're going
to get some more soon ah it's clearly I
mean like it keeps you cool it's very
comfortable
they're made of quality fabrics nice and
stretchy nice and stretchy and another
thing which you can appreciate if you're
like me is they have a lot really cool
designs it's not just black and white
they have stuff like this and like I
said very soft and you know if you're
not satisfied you can get your money
back and 20% off your first me andis
purchases I like to call that one nude
with excitement me honey's calms last
Jenna Julianne nude with excitable
because it is nude but then there's
excitement on top nude with accessible
your pale a little bit that's kind of
pale pale pale but with excitement pale
nude person who doesn't tan a lot but
it's also nude and excited excited on
their bottom neon DS m-e undies comm
slash Jenna Julian for 20% off guys let
us know and I know a lot of you guys
have already told us you like them so
thank you me Andes
thank you me undies yeah you know you
bring up a good point and I think the
the fact that Lady gaga
can't really out shock herself at this
point and she has kind of forced herself
to just like go back to the drawing
board a little bit it's a good example
of where shock takes you it gets you
like a lot of attention and then you
kind of have to figure something else
out and maybe it is true maybe Miley is
trying to like you know jumpstart people
a little bit
and say pay pal look at this you know I
mean completely polarizing or I think I
am or I'm doing things that I don't
think people are doing at all and you
know in a sense she's right
the nude thing where she's okay you know
not afraid to show her body on social
media and kind of in other contexts
that's that's fair I will agree that
that is not all horrible yeah it I think
and that's a matter of opinion
absolutely Bama grinning might be
serving some good no I'm agreeing with
that opinion what I what I stand by is
her her her attempts at getting
headlines and her attempts at humor and
I think maybe she would win me over just
not in the settings that she's been in
the VMA that was not her setting win me
over somewhere else you know do
something wild and different somewhere
else that just wasn't the place for it
it though it honestly felt a little bit
disrespectful just because there was a
lot of people there there's a lot of
people watching there's a lot of very
talented people not that Miley isn't but
for her to get out there and just kind
of be Miley like be that the weed
smoking Miley that she's been lately
just so in everyone's face it's just
like I feel like I wasn't the only one
who's just a little like cringy and kind
of over it I'm sure you would um but
yeah I mean III hear what you're saying
and I think I think Miley's next step or
a couple of steps or whatever she
decides to move towards next could be
something that I enjoyed greatly and a
lot of people could enjoy greatly or
appreciate or recognize as more of
substantial art or activities or
whatever she's doing I just think that
the way that she came off didn't make me
feel like being a fan of hers hmm I
can't understand that 100% all right
well I mean yeah laughs we appreciate
you like listening to my tirade it's all
good I just I think that Miley is very
talented I think that she comes from a
unique position and that she was a child
star and I wouldn't you know I can't say
what I would do in her shoes but I
understand
maybe coming from the Disney Channel
having a very famous dad you know being
treated like much younger than you are
for much longer than you are it's
probably very frustrating and annoying
and I don't want to be hanumant I'm he
and I'm my dad over the rest of my life
yeah I want to be myself yeah and her
feeling like she really needed to make a
big statement and continue to make a big
statement because once you make a big
statement the way that she did cutting
her hair and you know putting off album
very wrecking ball and all of that you
know once you go there you run the risk
of you know being called boring after
that like well what are you gonna do to
one-up yourself
yeah it's an impossible game to win yeah
so I did it just that's that's something
I'm taking away from what you're saying
it's a hard game to play and when when
you try to constantly one-up yeah but I
just I think there might be more to it
than that it might also just be a that
is who she really is
which is fine be she's trying to find
her own independence her own voice and
sometimes the only way to do that is to
really just give negative [ __ ] yeah well
I can I was appreciating her negative
[ __ ] zone last night because I saw those
outfits
I saw her hair yeah saw her performance
and I just its relates to Kanye to me I
appreciate anyone that is doing their
own thing and saying [ __ ] you to
everyone else
well here's like III think the negative
Fox thing and doing whatever she wants
is a great thing and I think that I've
seen her do that but I don't think last
night was as pure of an example of her
doing that it felt like she was like hey
look at how if you [ __ ] I'm giving look
at all the weed I smoked it was more
just like of her trying instead of just
not [ __ ] giving a [ __ ] like I've seen
instances where she just didn't care and
that that was that was something I can
understand because that's her trying to
find her voice and just not really care
at all but last night felt like it was
it was that but like well don't you feel
like there were expectations for her to
be a certain way and MTV had probably
pushed her into doing a couple of those
bits
yeah but MTV is at fault too because
they participated in all
those bets and I didn't like them I'm
serious like who I mean
you're right though you said it earlier
who would MTV was like okay let's make
45 wheat jokes and no one's gonna snow
in an mtv at the meeting is he like
that's a little much but that's also you
have to remember how they keep these
television award shows alive they need
to have controversial things happen they
need to keep themselves in the tabloids
the next day or else they can't afford
to keep having them every year I don't
disagree with it VMAs are historically
some of the most unruly award shows you
can go to like people MTV welcomes the
unexpected things to happen because they
want it to be controversial so my
assumption is you know Miley might not
be a great host she might make a bunch
of weed jokes but at least she's getting
us ratings MTV is participating in that
train of like we need right now no we
need that spur to happen we need to
orchestrate some drama and some
controversy or else there would be no
more VMAs because it's really hard to
get people to give a [ __ ] about what the
best video of the year is I don't really
give a [ __ ] fair enough
I'm not disagreeing I just hate that
that and that that is a thing I hate
that that dynamic exists I hate that
problem that is fed into I don't like it
mmm but I mean you're right like you're
right and maybe you didn't do it because
they were fans of Miley they did it
because they knew she was going to get
huge numbers
well yeah it's all sort of a [ __ ] up
yes no it's I don't needs MTV you can't
be on MTV's bad side yeah and no force
Miley to be Miley and maybe not who
Miley wants to be if it's different than
her image sure enough per like if Miley
was like sure I'd love to host the the
VMAs but you know I've been feeling kind
of tired of this stick lately is it cool
if I'm just myself
it would've been like oh [ __ ] off we'll
get someone else no can't do that right
you're right you're absolutely right um
have you heard any of her new album
no I the Dead Pat's one that she
announced no I was thinking of looking
at but then I got distracted with a
bunch of yeah it was late last night and
I had
listen to tangerine with her and Big
Sean and that was the only song I
listened to but it sounds different it
sounds it's not that different it's just
I'll check it out I want to check it out
and you know what maybe there needs to
be an eventual part two to this podcast
yeah for some closure but I just I
needed to get some of that off my chest
I will listen to her album I will I was
confused because there's like [ __ ] 25
songs on there Wow yeah she gives no
[ __ ] like that's no [ __ ] and some of
them are you know the weirdest titles
ever but do you do you and you just put
on an album for free and there's like a
billion songs on here
it's like the way you drop nightmare
fuel no [ __ ] is own yeah you're right
it's respected you're right you're right
I've learned some things and I've heard
you say some things in this podcast that
I did not think we're going to change
the way I felt and you have changed the
way I felt a little bit a little bit a
little bit a little bit hold that just a
little wee bit well what what are the
ones that you're still holding on to
she's not 100 sent to anyone mmm-hmm and
we don't have to keep hashing it up
right now all I'm saying is that like
I'll watch her and I want to see what
she does next cuz I do think it's an
interesting situation and I don't
necessarily think she's reached her
final form if you will well no one's
ever reached their final form you know
what I mean though well look at somebody
like Madonna that used to sell shock for
years and still tries to yeah it
eventually comes off kind of tired yeah
no you're right I think if anything Lady
Gaga is making a great choice and just
turning it around and being like oh [ __ ]
everyone I'm a real person yes yes stop
bringing costumes up that was me then
I'm just a little different now no just
whatever yeah I stole my throw ones yeah
this is weird I was every once in a
while because art son layered eyebrows
because I wanted to make a whole [ __ ]
album Tony Bennett [ __ ] everybody that's
what she said that's [ __ ] dope mm-hmm
well maybe Miley's in that weird stage
right now she'll figure well how old is
Miley
no.24 want me to look it up my guess is
25 our guests when I wake up I will look
up hold Miley Cyrus's but you know she's
not that old she's in her mid too young
to mid 20s mid too young to mid she's
what he do
22 Wow numbers oh I mean she's gone
through several transformations as a
professional already which is a lot that
is a liar 20 so there's a lot and she's
always dealt with a lot so I'll give her
a little slack here's a little slack
Miley she's giving you a make-believe
rope okay she took it thank you for
taking it Miley that's good I'm glad
maybe Miley should order some E and E so
she's not an agent they do feel nice on
your bun this feels so good you good
funk it goodbye pop kiss and papa
limitless any comments in the comments
let us know your comments in the
comments yeah be honest be honest you
did you hate what I said tell me hey
what I said and you call me a dick yeah
no not at all and um you're entitled to
urine pain your good English we've done
two podcast tonight we're Harding who
are Harding to English yeah and and no
vote for real feel free to be honest
because Julian what I appreciated was
that you were very honest yeah
and I appreciate you know maybe keeping
it PG don't be too mean about me or
Julian or Miley yeah keep it
constructive and be kind to each other
but be straight up and let's be honest
and tell us your thoughts because it's
an interesting thing and she has really
put herself out there and I'd be
interested to know people's opinions for
sure likewise and while you're at it
check out me undies calm that's Emmy
undies calm /gen
Julian yeah for 20% off the most
comfortable underwear you ever put on
that ass the most comfortable ever under
wherever you might put it on your head
and wear it as a hat
that's true Tara birthday party I've
worn that when it's a hat the nude
exciting yes well it gets weird in our
houses we love you guys we'll see you
next week